hide your boners and eat some delicious
dirt because we have the most
interesting thing to happen to women's
soccer since
well i can't name anything showtime's
yellowjackets is like if lost had a baby
with the rugby team who ate each other
so in this video we'll be taking a look
at season one's ending and answering
some of the show's biggest questions if
you haven't seen the show this might not
be the video for you as we'll be going
over a lot of the mystery i've left
timestamps to all the topics which also
contain theories for season two so feel
free to scroll through to whatever
interests you and last please consider
liking and subscribing or else my wife
will force me to live in the wilderness
i'm just kidding i don't have a wife who
is pit girl yes the very first scene of
the entire show contains one of its most
cryptic elements here we see an unknown
woman running through the wilderness
plummeting to her death in a spike laden
trap but when we take a look at the
clues we can get a better picture of
what's going on here first this is the
best image of the woman's face doesn't
really give us any insight who or even
if this is one of the survivors from the
plane crash the showrunners have also
confirmed they used body doubles for
some of the actors in the sequence as to
not give away any clues for season 2 but
there are a lot of cool things we can
still point out the woman is wearing a
clean white nightgown this is a stark
contrast to what the other survivors are
wearing and to me it feels very out of
place suggesting this is either a not
one of the survivors or b is one of the
survivors but may have been part of some
sort of ceremony or ritual i'll get more
into detail about the various rituals
we've seen taissa take part in later on
we haven't really gotten to know some of
the other survivors that were on the
plane like the one seen here during the
funeral service in episode 3. it's
possible it could be one of them but if
i were to make a guess pit girl is one
of the survivors who was chosen to be
eaten they cleaned her up and she was
about to be sacrificed in some sort of
ceremony but as we see she escapes i
can't wait to be proven totally wrong in
season two it's also a bit weird that
this person doesn't seem to know where
she's going she seems lost and
disoriented nor does she know where this
trap is something you'd think one of the
survivors would know now that could just
be because she's in hysteria just having
escaped or it could point at this not
being one of the survivors but then
there's this heart-shaped necklace the
last time we saw this in the 1996
timeline was when shauna gives it back
to jackie but as we know jackie dies at
the end of the season i'm cold too well
damn jackie i can't control the weather
we also know pit girl can't be one of
the present day survivors and it's
probably not lottie or van we see this
person hovering over the pit who i think
is van judging by the type of mask she
is wearing and the naked coed soccer
shirt we've seen her wear in previous
episodes we'll see van as one of
lottie's followers at the end of the
season notice also these pink shoes i
went and scrubbed through every episode
but couldn't find anyone wearing an
identical pair to match up but if you've
seen something similar let me know in
the comments below where are they now
this one is easy to miss since it's
explained by the pilot over the plane's
pa system while shauna and jackie are
talking the plane was headed from new
jersey to seattle but due to a storm the
route would be diverting north into the
canadian rockies it's pretty vague how
far north they went and since misty
broke the flight recorder at the end of
episode 2 it explains why no one came
for them and that's also a great
question who would want to break one of
the only means of being found well it
would be someone who wouldn't want to be
found misty is such a tragic character
and one who is so desperate to be loved
and connect with others that she'd break
the one thing that could get all of them
back to civilization throughout episode
2 we see how all the characters praise
misty for her ingenuity knowledge of
survival and first aid this is the first
time in her life that she feels that
she's wanted and part of something we
would be so completely [ __ ] if she
wasn't here
this world in the wilderness she is
wanted and admired and the flight
recorder represents a threat to that
this is the same reason misty kills
jessica roberts if she were to go and
tell the true story of what happened to
the girl she'd be losing these friends
but there's something more here these
girls are trauma bonded and we haven't
even scratched the surface at the things
they did in order to survive if the true
story came out of what they actually did
it would be devastating to all of them
and season 2 will delve deeper into this
one of the things implied in season one
is cannibalism but as jessica pointed
out if they had to eat one of the others
to survive it would only make people
sympathize with their plight even more
people would understand just like how
the public understood how the survivors
of a uruguayan rugby team had to do what
they had to to survive this points at
something more here could it be that
this cannibalism wasn't necessary and
are there other acts even more gruesome
yet to be revealed the symbol and the
postcard throughout the season we've
seen this symbol it's been carved on
trees found in the upstairs attic of the
captain's cottage as well as the
mysterious postcards the survivors
receive now if you do a quick google
reverse image search there is no match
for this symbol it's been created
specifically for the show however there
have been some interesting theories out
there as to what it really means one is
that it's composed of what are called
hobo symbols symbols used by hobos to
communicate with others that indicate
things like danger or here as a safe
space but it's not entirely accurate the
other is that it has something to do
with trigonometry trig being something
of an easter egg throughout the season
not one of those girls gave a good god
damn about trigonometry i can tell you
that much and one of the more
interesting theories out there comes
from redditer shutup i love that who
believes it may be a diagram for how to
hang and skin a deer but if i were to
take a stab at this i think it's purely
a symbol to represent lottie's cult that
doesn't need to be broken down into its
constituent parts does the symbol
predate lottie well even that is up for
debate we can't 100 be sure the symbol
found in the attic was carved before
they got there because it was lottie who
was the first one up there when the
symbol is seen carved in the tree well
lottie could have easily carved that too
as to who sent those postcards well i
think it's lottie perhaps even with the
help of misty which leads us to just who
in the hell is lottie and is she
actually possessed by some sort of
spirit we don't know much about lottie's
upbringing in a flashback to when she
was really young we see how her
premonitions started when she distracts
her father and they avoid a car crash
we'll later see her overhear her parents
talking about her condition her mother
thinks she can actually predict the
future while her father thinks she needs
medication in a very brief scene from
episode 1 we see lottie who comes from
an affluent home with a maid take a pill
of loxopene a medication used to treat
schizophrenia so is she a schizophrenic
who has happened to sway people into
believing her psychosis or does she
actually possess the ability to see into
the future that's one of the things the
writers have publicly stated they love
exploring in the show the gray area
between what is real and not what can be
explained and unexplained almost all of
the strange occurrences that have
happened can be explained in multiple
ways did lottie really hold sway over a
grizzly bear who let her stab it so they
can eat or was it just sick and weak
just like the deer they hunted a few
days ago as misty says of opinions in
episode 2 quoting plato opinion is the
wilderness between knowledge and
ignorance anyway you slice it lottie
does have a good track record at these
predictions and it only seems to get
better as she accrues more and more
followers at the end of the season we
find out that lottie is still possibly
alive and was the one behind closing
travis's bank account meaning lottie was
likely behind travis's death and a big
cover-up has happened speaking of
travis's death i can't help but think
misty was somehow involved at the end of
the finale we see misty as one of
lottie's followers as she sacrifices the
bear's heart just to whom this sacrifice
is too we don't know there's only been
vague references to quote the old gods
of the dirt and sky dirt is an
interesting choice of words here since
we've seen taiss in her dream state
eating dirt on multiple occasions misty
wasn't that shocked when she bore
witness to travis's hanging and she was
also the one to notice how wax stains on
the ground created the symbol the wax
stains suggest candles which we've seen
all around lottie during one of
hallucinations and also hints that a
ceremony or ritual was done when travis
was killed misty also knows a ton about
getting away with murders she's a true
crime fanatic and i can't help but think
she's somewhat of an inside man for
lottie and whatever it is she wants
speaking of inside man or woman let's
talk about taissa or should i call her
senator taissa this has got to be our
lady in the tree who we've heard
mentioned throughout the season mainly
by sammy who he says watches her from
his window at night that's why he's
blocked it with pictures we've also seen
taissa wake up in a tree in episode 7
and also wake up outside the home's
garden taeys's actions can be explained
two ways one that the stress of the
election has caused her to enter a
protective state while sleepwalking that
makes her do things she might otherwise
not have done and this protective state
also happened when she was under stress
in 96 or there's a more supernatural
explanation she comes under control of
lottie or this woodland spirit when she
sleepwalks but interesting to note this
only seems to happen under extreme
stress both in 1996 and the election
campaign of 2021. now i don't know about
you but this final shot we get at her
smirking after her victory seems to hint
that this other side of her may be
taking over and if it means getting what
she wants she'll probably be open to it
after all we're talking about the girl
who willingly tackled her teammate
breaking her bones so that she couldn't
be a liability in the nationals but
since at least at this point she doesn't
know she's doing this stuff in her sleep
we can let her off the hook and we know
that bite she got digging in the dirt
was now from their decapitated dog
biscuit which leads us to the secret in
taissa's basement near the end of the
finale simone finds a ritual-like shrine
containing their sons smash doll their
severed dog's head heart and yup more
candles it seems to be a collection of
things cherished by their son sacrificed
in order for her to win the election
simone is alerted to this hidden part in
their basement when a draft one strong
enough to move the pants on their
clothesline alerts her to a vent covered
in blood so she does the only rational
thing and follows it to a secret room
this draft suggests there's another
entrance leading outside which might be
this right here perhaps a hidden door
some have theorized that it might be van
who orchestrated this ritual or at least
helped in some way sammy did draw a
picture of a red-haired woman and the
blood looks too fresh for the kill to
have been done by taisa who has been at
campaign headquarters all day one thing
we really don't know a lot about is the
fate of shauna's baby who if alive would
be around 25 years old in 2021 shauna
and jeff the mother and father don't
seem to talk about it nor their daughter
cali shauna doesn't even talk about it
to the other survivors if there's one
thing that is so damning that girls
won't tell their story my guess is it
might revolve around this baby the big
question is what happened to it the
writers themselves actually don't know
one of the writers has stated that they
currently have 10 different ideas about
what happens to it and although we do
see shauna eating her chicken baby it's
likely the baby won't be used as a meal
but the writers haven't ruled it out and
what about the man with no eyes it's
most likely just a manifestation of what
taissa thought her grandmother saw he
can be seen briefly in the opening
credits along with another mysterious
character we only see for a moment
jackie's death dream introduces us to a
person built in the credits only known
as hunter whether this is his name or
profession we aren't exactly sure but it
does seem as though jackie may know who
he is or at least he knows of her saying
the line we've been waiting for you i'm
thinking this is someone who may have
died in the past here as lottie says of
the cabin
bad things happened
it's possible this guy could be the same
person whose plane they found and whose
body was discovered in the attic who
knows we may even get some form of
ghosts next season now hear me out the
writers have confirmed they've been
thinking of interesting ways to bring
jackie's character back and if we've
already seen this dude who's to say
jackie can't come back as a ghost or
some form of guilt the girls feel for
what they did to her are there other
survivors that will meet in present day
yes the writers have confirmed we will
be meeting at least one other survivor
as an adult in present day we might even
see more we also don't know the fate of
javi but judging that his brother travis
in present day nor any of the girls
mention him it's not looking good the
final episode leaves with travis and nat
searching for him what was the point of
adam was he really just there as some
artist who shauna killed for no reason
the short answer yes in an interview
with yahoo one of the writers explained
quote how sad would it be if adam really
was just a guy who fell in love with
shauna but that because of what had
happened to her it was an impossibility
for her to accept that end quote it was
shauna's paranoia something that may
have been vital for her survival in the
wilderness that would ultimately end up
killing the person she was falling in
love with does misty kill coach ben i
mean the writers have certainly set this
up with her love affair and her finding
out that he's gay misty did attempt
poisoning him in the past it might be
one of those scenarios if she can't have
him no one can but there's a lot to play
around with this next season and you bet
misty will be pissed ben lied about
being interested in her finally lottie's
last words it's pretty much confirmed
that lottie ends up being what some of
us online have been calling the antler
queen we see her wearing the same antler
horns and similar attire on doom's
coming as is seen in the opening of
episode 1. in episode 6 it's a male deer
with beautiful antlers that lead her to
a bunch of candles during her baptism
hallucination and check out the shot of
her framed in front of the antlers as
lottie gives at the bearheart in what
appears to be some sort of offering she
says the french line verse
me which translates to shed blood my
beautiful friends remember that lottie
did take french in high school although
one of the girls said she sucked at it
this is followed by the english line and
let the darkness set us free so it's
pretty ominous what she has in store but
i want to hear what you think is the
show about a bunch of kids dealing with
trauma or do we have a malevolent spirit
on our hands is lottie crazy or has
something taken control of her i'm
curious to hear what you think thanks
for watching everyone if you liked the
video be sure to like and subscribe and
for more bad takes you can always follow
me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you